。
我们先来探讨几个问题啊探讨先节拍拉完了，我先来探讨几个问题，待会再聊一句话故事，待会儿再聊故事类型，待会儿再聊谁是主角，待会儿再聊。
先啊先探讨几个小问题。我们说这部电影啊，我们说它可是标准的打上业片是吧？我们说前后呼应做的好不好？同学们red的前后呼应第一场戏，中间那场戏，最后那场戏三场戏。
全是前后呼应，对不对？其实安迪也是啊安迪的前后呼应呢，我们说red有自己属于自己的开头和结局，安迪有没有属于自己的开头和结局啊？安迪从银行中来到银行中去啊，第一场戏西装革履在银行，最后一场戏西装革履在银行啊，当然了，第一场在法庭，但是他是当时是银行CEO。
银行CEO对不对？
我们说。
从一个西装革履的银行银金融人再次回到西装革履的金融人啊。
一切都是一个循环，整个片子十分的工整啊十分的工整。
同学我们先研究第一个问题啊。
四目师，我们分一分吧。
同学们有没有兴趣分一分四目式啊？我们说第一幕我们说。
分思路式，我们先不要去按照时间去分啊，不要按照时间去刻板的分，没有那么准呀。一般来说一坨二十来分钟，有时候还三十来分钟嘞，对不对？我们说先不要按照时间去分啊，先不要按照时间去分。
我们先来说一下四目式的定义啊，启程转合启是干什么？建立目标城是什么？强化目标，追求目标。
直到获得虚假的胜利，转是什么？故事带来方向性的转变，那产生新的目标，需要有新的目标，甚至有了危机，有了牺牲，对吧？和呢？
兑现目标。
兑现最初的模。
对吧用另外一种方式兑现最初。
既然是这样。
我们来看一下旗是。
按照我们刚才的30拍或者31拍起是1到7。
1到7，我给大家拉一下位置，为什么说是1到7呢？为什么说是1到7拍呢？我们说这里要建立目标，故事讲述的是刚刚进入监狱的。
没有罪的安迪跟这个监狱格格不入的安迪开始要。
适应监狱生活。
并且在监狱当中。
寻找希望和自由，他要适应监狱的生活。我们说他要适应监狱的生活。
有同学老说姐妹团出场，同学姐妹团的出场不应该成为一个标志啊。同学们姐妹团的出场不应该成为标志。我来告诉大家，第一场第一幕是从哪里到哪里啊。我们来看啊，我刚才说的第一幕是建立目标，他开始要适应这里的生活。
掉了吗？
来，这是第一幕的结束。我们说这个姐妹团的危险提前给了啊，姐目团的危险提前在第一幕给了，因为第一幕比较空嘛，把姐妹团的危险提前往前提了一下，但这不影响这里还是第一幕。我们说这是第二幕的开始。
看一下这场戏。
这是第二幕的开始。
主角上路了。
为什么说主角上路了呢？他开始真正的适应监狱生活，并且追求自由了。我们说这是第二幕。
第二幕。
他开始买锤子，开始追求。
然后我们说第二幕讲的是他在监狱当中一步一步如鱼得水，直到获得虚假的胜利。第二幕是25到65。
哦，25分钟到65分钟节拍的话是第八拍到第21排。也就是说。
在这里。
又不理我了。
获得唱片。
这场戏是非常有代表性的一场戏啊，虚假的胜利甚至都开始听上音乐了。他自己自认为在监狱里已经混到顶峰了。我们说在这里。
其实你回想一下我们的主角安迪是不是在这个时刻他在监狱的地位是最高的？
在这一时刻，他在监狱的地位是最高的。
好吧。
然后开始转。
急转直下啊急转直下。
他开始成为了一个毁。
我们说转这里啊。
音乐事件啊之后，他开始沦彻底沦为洗黑钱的工具，远有一场非常标志性的信息给大家看一下。
look卖给谁。
看一下这场戏，没有盖章。
And just't make a person up. sure you can. You know how the system works where the cracks are. It's amazing what you can accomplish by mail.
D. Stevens has a birth certificate driver's license, Social Security number if they ever trace any of those accounts, they're going to wind up chasing a figment imagination.
对对呀。
他是一个 good。
这就是明白来的。
发ing is。
On the outside as an honest man, straight as an narrow.
别怪。
来。
我们说这场戏。
讲的是。
安底施记成为了罪人。
这是转第22到26场，好吧。
来和。
27到30。
当然你也可以说到3131我认为是附赠的一个结局啊，和可以理解为27到30讲的是安迪。
终于忏悔了自己。
终于赎完了自己的罪行。
找到了。
真正的自由。
精神和肉体全部的自由。因为在第。
四目的第一场戏，第四幕的第一场戏，也就是100分钟整的时候，同学们。
第四幕的第一。
100分钟整的时候。
安迪宣告自己。
赎罪结束。
他在这里彻底的忏悔了自己。
来，同学们。
这时候四目式就比较清楚了，我们再来理一下啊。
讲的是什么？
里面。
你就知道一句话故事和这个故事的性质是什么了。
我们说。
来，我们说一个。
一个。
没有罪的人。
一个没有罪的人。
被关进了重刑犯的监狱。
而且是一个正直善良，甚至有点文弱，文质彬彬的知识分子被关到了一个重刑犯的监狱。我们说这样一个人被关到这里来之后，他要怎么办呀？
他显然要想办法适应这个它不属于的环境。
也就是说我们讲。
所有的电影故事创意讲的全都是mson impossible，记不记得啊？
所有的故事创意讲的都是不可能完成的任务。那我们这部片子显然讲的是一个一个非常不属于监狱的人，一个文质彬彬的银行高管、知识分子。
而且还细皮嫩肉，手无缚鸡之力，正直善良这么一个人关键的重刑犯的监狱，他要想办法去适应这里的环境，面对那些坏人，面对那些狱警，面对那些他妈狱友没一个好东西，他适应这里的环境。所以说他首先要做的是适应环境。
然后随着他在这里，对吧？他用他自己的方法找他自己内心的平静，甚至一直还保持希望。他慢慢的竟然适应了环境，而且还而且还。
适应的非常好，在故事终点的时候，甚至成为了这个这个监狱拥有特权的那个人。
甚至成为了这个监狱的他妈狱长秘书，对吧？我们知道秘书能当半哪家呀，是吧？于成为了狱长秘书。
顶半边天。
碰到顶峰的手候。
但是与此同时，他混好了，确实是适应这个监狱的环境了。
在这时候。
却变成了罪恶的帮凶。
本来寻找在这里想要适应环境，是想通过。
他想通过寻找自己的内心的平静，对吧？寻找自己的内心的平静，想寻找自己内心的平静。想想想想。
讲这个这个这个。
想想想保持希望来保证来保持他在这里的生存。但没想到他混到顶峰，混到虚假的胜利，其实他也已经是一个罪人了。
实际上他也已经是一个罪人。
而且。
认为最有希望的东西就是他教别人要拥有希望，教别人要好好学习，教别人要重新做人。
的那个徒弟的代表。
那个汤米是他影响别人帮助别人的一个代表作。
死了。
而且因他而死。
故事进入灵魂黑夜。
最终他决定。
还是要做一个正直的人。
我们说故事终点调整目标啊，对吧？
他最早。
这个这个这个。
获得虚假胜利。然后后来呢就是成为了一个坏人，调整目标错误。
依旧是错误的，再次回到正途，重新追求希望。
故事的第四幕。
追求内心和肉体双重的希希望。我们说咱们现在看到这场戏是第四幕的，咱们现在看到这场戏是第四幕的。
开始。
他重新忏悔自己。
重新重想要重新重新做人。
重新重新做人。
然后呢，在这场戏决定他要出去，因为这场戏明确的他跟red已经开始交代后事了，你出去怎么找我。
明白这个分布吧。
这个故事的一句话故事。
很显然是。
一个含冤入狱的。
被关在重刑犯的这么一个老实人。
就一个老实人，一个含冤入狱的关在重刑犯监狱的这么一个老实人。
面对什么情况啊？
面对腐败黑暗的狱警、典狱长以及凶恶残忍的狱友。
仍然坚持。
寻找自由和希望。
仍然坚持寻找自由和希望，那么就非常明确了。
从救猫咪的角度来说，这个故事属于被制度化。
被制度化，对不对？
我们说被制度化啊这样一个困境。
被制度化这样一个困境。
被制度化的定义是什么来呢？
就是一个闯入体制的外来者。我们说这一句词儿就基本上奠定了这部片子就是被制度化的典型代表了。
一个闯入体制的外来者，他就是一个闯入体制的外来者呀。
他是整个肖申克唯一一个没无罪的人啊。
他是整个肖申克唯一一个没有罪的人。
一个闯入体制的外来者。
然后呢。
他要么被这个体质吞噬。
要么改变这个体质，逃离出去。
逃离和改变，对吧？
那我们就非常明确了，我们说。
我们要创作一个被知乎制度化的故事的时候，我们会设计一个闯入者，再设计一个体制。然后当局的对抗拉锯是什么？就是这个闯入者要么被体制吞噬，要么他改变和破和逃离体制。同学们。
这个故事是不是这样的？一个闯入者进到一个体制，两种拉锯，要么被体制吞噬。
要么改变和逃离这个体制。
那我们看肖申克的旧书不就讲了这两件事吗？
他前半段被体质吞噬了，他后半段改变和逃离这个体质了。
对不对啊？
他就做了这两件事情啊，拉锯啊一直在这两件事情里面拉锯啊。
先吞噬这一半，然后改变了。
非常明确的啊非常明确的这么一个被制度。
非常明确的一个被制度。
他的一句话故事也非常明确了，四目式也非常明确。
那我们再来看一下。
救赎。
这部片子。
我们说中文翻译的这个名字啊要比他原版要高级啊。
他原版叫肖申克是吧？他原版叫肖申克啊。
然后呢。
我们这个故事啊我们这个故事啊叫。
呃，中文翻译叫肖申克的救赎啊，我们说救赎啊更重要，实际更重要啊实际更。
我们说。
都有谁救赎啊？
我们说首先。
他妻子。
和那个奸夫。
来都救出了谁？除了安迪和red以外。
还救赎了谁？我们说安y和red比较好理解，其他的狱友也相对好理解，对吧？然后典狱长和典狱长也好理解吧，tommy也就赎了。我们说典狱长也好理解吧，典狱长最后是不是也罪有应得，对吧？那同学们不要不要漏掉开场。
ay那就快。
Glf pro at the Snowden Hills Country Club, the man you had recently discovered was your wife's lover.
A few bars first Later I drove to his house to confront them they weren't home.
Confuse.
自杀妻这里，非常确自没杀他也明自杀啊同学。
自己没看没看仔细啊 where I get hazy is where the cleaning woman shows up the following morning and finds her wife in bed with her lover riddled with 38 caliber bullets.
Does that strike you as a fantastic coincidence, Mr. Derainer is it just me it does that you still maintain you threw your gun into the river before the murders took place, that's very convenient.
drag that river for three days and na a gun was found, so there could be no comparison made between your gun and the bullets taken from the bloodstained corpses of the victims.
That also is very convenient, isn't it Mr. Defr?
Since I am innocent of this crime, sir, I find it decidedly inconvenient that the gun was never found.
Ladies and gentlemen you've heard all the evidence you know the facts we have the accused of the scene of the crime, we have footprints, tire tracks, bullets strewn on the ground with bears fingerprints, a broken bobon ball, likewise with fingerprints, and most of all, we have a beautiful young woman and her lover lying dead in each other's arms.
They很吃。
We have the accused of the scene of the crime, we have footprints, tire tracks, bullets stwn on the ground with various fingerprints, broken bo bomb likewise with fingerprints, and most of all, we have a beautiful young woman and her lover lying dead in each other's arms.
对。
好。
同学们，其实你们看一下啊，连这场戏都在强调有罪无罪。
整体来说，整部电影都是关于有罪和救赎。
谁有罪谁无罪，他想说人人有罪啊，人人都有罪，就看你有不能能不能救赎。包括安迪，他在第四幕的第一场啊，第四幕的第一场，也就是节拍咱们节拍的第。
2十7拍安迪也忏悔自己是有罪。
安迪也忏悔自己是有罪的，明白吗？也就是说，在这部电影当中，其实通篇在讲救赎。
这就是我为什么说我们这个灵魂翻译啊，其实是比原版。
只叫肖申克啊要来的更有灵魂。
修申克的救赎，这个片名更有灵魂啊，对不对？也就是这个片中出现的所有人实际都有罪。
也都一定程度。
救赎了。
那个典狱长最后吞枪自杀，对吧？在圣经的照耀下，吞枪，先学几个知识点。
刚才有同学问说。
最早的时候有同学说这部电影是不是金羊毛啊，不是有之前咱们其实接触过有很多片子，有很多越狱类型的片子啊，实际是金羊毛。
我们说这部片子为什么不是这样？
区别是啥？
我们说金羊毛的片子啊是以目标为导向。
我们说为什么有很多越狱的片子是金羊毛？因为上来就说我要越狱，然后四目确定第一幕确定越狱这个目标。第二幕呢为越狱这个目标去努力。第三幕呢发现我操努力错了，再要换一个方法，然后再去越。第四幕呢发现我操还是最好的最早的方法是好的。
然后再越狱成功，明白吗？
你们自己去体会一下这里面的区别，一个片子是以是有它的脉络和目标的。
你如果是一个以越狱为目标的金羊毛类型的片子，那你在第一幕要提出目标呀。
咱们这个片子越狱这个目标啥时候提过啊？
咱们这个片子没有提过越狱这个目标呀，从头到尾没有为这个目标去努力呀。当然，安迪有偷偷努力，我是说在咱们电影这个故事叙述当中没有为越狱这个目标去铺陈去努力呀。
我们不是团队的问题，我们主要聊的不是团队。你们如果还在在那说团队，就说明你们没根本没有理解我在说什么这部电影。
一直在讲。
安迪如何适应这个监狱的环境，这才是他的主目标。
他要融入这个它不属于的环境，这才是这部电影的主脉络。
明白吗？
你我为什么说我每次找故事类型都找的比你们准，很多同学都找不准，是因为你们根本没有带入编剧去思考。你们觉得编剧在写这个剧本的时候，每一场戏都在写编剧安迪越狱越到第一部了，越狱越到第二部了。呃，越狱找到第三个同伴了，找到第四个道具了，又找到第五个路径了。
哪有这件事情啊。
这部电影哪有讲这个东西啊，你这个故事根本不是按照越越狱这个目标去打点的，根本不是按照这个脉络去去组织的。
全都是按照安迪来到一个不他不属于的环境，他怎么去适应如何在这个环境混好了，但是其实是迷失了，然后再去写这个故事的。
所以完全不是金阿毛的。
这个套路去写的还刚才还有个同学说。
伙伴之情，那就更不是了呀。这部片子我跟你说，re都谈不上，是拿2号，他怎么能有伙伴之情，而且两个人哪有揪心的分分合合啊，对不对啊？哪有啊。
并没有嘛。
再来学一下，我们说这部片子啊，同学们这部片子。
用了一个我其实不太提倡的东西，就是旁白。我们说旁白实际上有利有弊呀。
这部电影的旁白有些什么样的作用？这部片子的旁白有些什么样的作用？
这个旁白。
确实是加出来。
他用安y的视角，他用red的视角来讲述整个故事，增加亲历感。
是吧他用red这个视角讲述我有一个神奇的朋友。
我们讲。
这种叙事方式。
当年是很具备亲切感。
就是有一个人告诉你。
我有一个非常牛逼的朋友，对吧？我们说这种故事啊在小说题里面啊当年是很多的。但其实这个小说原本原文不是这么写。
同学马上想起了了不起的盖茨比。
我们说用red。
作为一个亲历者。
增加。
真实性。然后。
同时。
由于这个故事跨度长达20年，用一个旁白也可以更好的梳理线索。同学们记不记得？我在课上说，我说我我希望咱们新手写电影的时候啊，尽量写小而集中的时间是吧？小而美。
比如说你要写越狱，那就写越狱这15天到底是怎么计划，集中实件好写。
但是他写了一个跨度20年的故事，按理说挺费劲的。
但是跨度20年的故事没有旁白。
那就很难写呀。所以说。
用这个还有第三个作用。
就是。
这部电影啊其实讲了很多道理。
那讲了到底什么是希望？
讲了人为什么而活着，对吧？
讲讲了很多所谓的道理，所谓金剧啊，这个旁白啊比较容易体现这些东西啊。在90年代初期啊，这个这种做法啊当时看来啊还是比较流行，甚至有一点点高级啊。但是现在的电影21世纪的电影大家都是来看叙事的。
讲太多道理啊，观众未必爱听。
你一用一个很有磁性的男中音。
比如说你想象一下橘峥大鹏在那演一个电影，然后旁边有一个很有磁性的男中音告诉你。
生活。
往往是一团乱麻。
你身在其中。
理不出头绪。
但是你如果跳出来回顾他。
往往又知道其中的缘由。
但是等你看明白的时候。
或许。
就已经晚了。
不是吗？
你就会觉得别叨叨了，赶紧给我对吧？赶紧给我讲故事就完事了呗。90年代或许是可以的，明白吧？好，这就是关于旁白啊，同学们我们要知道啊。
学一部电影，学一部片子要全面的学知其然知其所以然啊，全都客观的分析人家为什么这么做，人家为什么取得了这么棒的成绩，这样你才能学你才能学到东西啊，学第二个知识点。
就是关于这部片子的关键道具。这部片子有个关键道具是圣经，是圣经。我们说这个圣经啊，他用了N多次，包括那个。
那个典狱长，他老婆是弄了个十字绣还是什么？对吧？讲是主主日审判即将来临，都是各种圣经的呃名名句吧，非常的契合剧情，包括那个救赎之道就在其中。我们说这个圣经这个关键道具啊。
对这个片子啊呃起到了画龙点睛的作用啊，既是个线索型的道具，又是个实用型的道具，它能藏追锤子呀，对吧？同时呢又是一个象征性的道具，它是个精神层面的道具。所以说圣经这个东西啊，在里面用的很好啊，这就带来一个思考啊，同学们思考一下。
有没有这两种同学？
第一种同学认为。
哎呀，这么用确实挺高级。
挺有范儿的啊，挺格儿的。
那我也用吧，对吧？就他也去在他的故事当中也去有意无意的。比如说他是个谋杀案啊，他就有意无意的引入七宗罪啊，引入各种这个这个这个比喻啊，引用这个各种典故。
啊，这是第一种同学。
啊，我然后呃我们的同学当中就有这种啊用这个搞创作。然后还有第二种同学就会瞧不起第一种同学觉得哎呀呀呀，你可丢死人了。西方的东西，圣经是西方的东西，关我们什么事呢？
我们要用就用佛经，佛经不是讲贪嗔吃饭吗？不是讲这个道法轮回嘛，这这个佛经道或者佛经或者道家，对吧？我们讲我们的东西，我们说这是第二种同学啊，这两种同学呢这种创作习惯创作方法呢都大量出现在。
咱们的练习当中啊，出现在咱们的作业当中。
同学们觉得这样好吗？第一种显而易见是错误的。因为呢。
因为呢。
这个这个这个。
圣经的东西啊，它不是我们中国的文化啊，也不是我们的呃故事背景，引不起我们的共鸣。那第二种呢？
实际也是错误的。
你不能说把圣经类比成我们的佛经，类比成我们的佛教，你就接地气了。
实际也不是。
为啥？
因为所因为我们说人家这部片子为什么用圣经啊？为什么用圣经，人家用的很好，用的很契合。
因为人家的文化里面，人家的观众，因为这部片子人家是美国片儿，人家天天就在那儿研究圣经，天天就在那想赎罪，天天在那忏悔，天天在那背。咱们中国人日常生活中其实也没有人天天研究佛经。
就你把圣经类比成佛经，他也不类比，我们也没有天天研究佛经。
我们也没有天天做件什么事儿，就我操，我是不是有罪呀，我犯了贪欲。
我犯了真欲，我刚才生气了。
我们也没这么想。
所以说你套上佛经改成东方文化。
也不接地气。那我们那我们中国人，我们中国人有我们自己的规则，对吧？比如说你看啊我给大家举个例子啊，我给大家举个例子啊，我们中国文化哪些是我们传统？
吃顿火锅非常对。
我们中国有饭局文化。
所以你看啊中国的戏里面啊吃饭比别人。
我们有饭局文化。
吃饭比别人。
你自己回想一下，咱们中国的影视剧是不是饭局就比西方。
我们有饭局。
我们还有什么文化？
我们有亲情文化、大庭文化你看我们中国写戏啊。
角色当中啊有很多人都是亲戚，谁是谁的弟弟，谁是谁的阿姨，对吧？我们有这个亲戚，包括孝道也是我们。
这些东西是可以体现在我们的创作当中，成为我们创作当中的潜规则，然后帮助我们接地气，而不是圣经，也不是谈嗔吃饭。我们没有。
很深的。
眷练再来看。
下一个知识点。
刚才有很多同学说，哎呀，这是不是双男主呀，是不是伙伴之情啊，是个red，为什么不是主角呀？回答一下这个问题。
同学们。
这部片子。
配角是什么？
主角是安迪，这个没有争议吧。
我们说主角的人设是什么？
主角是肖申克唯一一个。
无罪的人。
来，同学们，你们现在是我的学生，我告诉你们，假设没有这个电影，我告诉你们。
你现在给我写一个在一个监狱里唯一一个无罪的人作为主角。
请你现在给我设计配角，你的脑子里面想的是啥？同学们。
我现在给你下这个命令，我说主角是肖申克唯一一个无罪的人，你现在给我设计点配角。
你怎么设计，你肯定就马上接到命令，那我就设计形形色色有罪的人。
说对了。
形形色色有罪的人。
有的有罪，但不知悔改。
有的有罪悔改了，但是困在这里出不去。
有的有罪也悔改了，但是在这里不想出去。
对吧有的没有被定罪，看起来是执法者，但其实比所有人都有罪。
不就是形形色色有罪的人。
这就是这部电影配角的设计思路呀。
那么red是谁呀？
read就是其中一个。
品相比较好，我们拽过来让他做这个故事的讲述者。所以。
这部片子当中。
我们主角和伙伴的关系。
一会儿是和right的发生。
一会儿是和汤米发生。
一会儿适合。
典狱长发生。
一会儿是个老不发生。
你可以理解这些所有的配角，没有人称得上是男2号或者是所谓的双。
都不配养。
都不配。
我们说连共谋都不是。
re一块儿做的呀。
对不对？共谋就是跟大家一起。
做的呀。
所以说我们主角是绝对的男移，其他人都谈不上啊，都扮演了一种有罪的人。
只不过red是那个被安迪自我救赎的时候，顺便一起救赎。
同学也发现了老布的长结局也是很差。
老布根本不差事儿啊，这种卡这种级别的角色怎么配有一个七八分钟的结局呢？而且是单人solo，就吧七八分钟看不到主角能行吗？
形形色色有罪的人。
当然了，严格来说，安迪也有罪，或者他本来对他妻子的。
不是也是一种罪，你可以这么去理解。
所以说今天咱们最重要的结论。
还始。
你要学会这种片子怎么写？同学们回到我们最初。
我们说我们写一部片子，回到我们最初，我们写一部片子。
我们要写一个没有罪的人被扔进了一个最险恶的监狱，这就是我们最初的一个概念。
那我们就可以写把它打点配角，然后呢，让他先适应这里，然后再适应了之后，就让他先适应，心安理得的适应这里，然后再让他在这里失去一切，然后再让他出去就这么四个节拍，对吧？你整体来这么去想。
这部片子是不是？
没有那么吓。
没有那么复杂。
同学们通过我们刚才拆解节拍，拆解四幕式，拆解谁是主角，以及它的故事线，四幕是怎么搭的。你现在想一想这个片子是不是也没有那么复杂，没有那么吓人。
是不是也能写出来？
如果让你写一个同学们，我们现在类比一个。
同学们，我现在类比一个。
我们写一个插插班生的故事。
我们写一个学校，然后扔进来一个学生，这个学生根本不属于这里。
一个学校。
对吧一个制度化的学校扔进来一个插班生。
根本不属于这里吉布士。
会不会写了？
他先怎么适应终点达到什么样的虚假胜？
围绕着身边，围绕着一群什么样形形色色的人，最后他迷他也迷失了，他成为这里的老大了，他也迷失了，但是呢付出了惨痛的代价。
最后还是要决定要改变这个制度，要改变这个班级。
你是不是就会写啦？
是不是就会写啦？
脑子里面有没有脉络啊？
同样的不光是学校啊。
光是学校啊。
医院啊。
帮呀。
对吧？
贪腐的一个什么呀？
一个邪恶的什么呀？
脑子里面是不是有概念了？
扔进来一个人。
他是个什么人？
怎么给他设计伙伴？他是开始的目标是什么？
如何一步一步走向巅峰？
巅峰即是深渊呀。
走向巅峰，巅峰就是深渊，然后再幡然回悟，惹出大祸死人了。
重新找回自己。
再走出去。
以后。
遇到所有这种类型的片子是不是就不慌啦？
同学们啊，你以后遇到所有这种类型的片子，有这种类型片子的征稿，比赛或者是作业，你是不是就不慌了？
干他呀。
而且你按照这种结构写出来，有一种莫名的高级感呀。
咱们这个屋的人会觉得这很套路，出了这个屋，谁知道这是套路啊？
人家就会觉得我操高级呀。
懂吗？
这就是今天拉片的意义。
学那么一丢丢，遇到这种类型，我们就不慌了。
会写。
而且上来就很简单的就写了三十几拍，最起码能写出二十几拍，然后丰满一下这个戏100分钟至少能撑下来呀。
对不对？100分钟的职场能撑下来。
会写了吧。
一个格格不入的人。
扔进一个环境，正篇我们以后会写了，而且一定是绝对男医。什么刷男主啊给他配一堆配角。
包括他的对手都是配员。
都是跟他相反的人。
一堆。
明白吗？
有个同学问激地事件。
被制度化这种类型的片子啊，它的激励也就是说激励他产生原始目标啊，激励他产生原始目标。实际上一般来说是需要有的。但这部片子确实没有激励他产生追求自由的目标，因为这个主角设定它本身就很强。
所以说他进来之后呢，他在第25分钟，也就是第八拍自然而然的就去找。
re去寻找它的这种。
这是什么寻找他的第一个。
这个自由的希望，也就是说他要开始玩雕刻，明白吗？
所以说这个片子啊大家千万不要理解入狱是他的激励啊，入狱不是他的激励，他在狱中是他的现状，入狱那场戏开场戏不是他的激励，不是他的激励。咱们别去这么理解，好吧，因为激励的作用是让主角产生目标。
这这部戏当中，主角的目标是融入这个环境，寻找希望和自由，是在这个环境当中寻找和希望和自由。这个我们这个主角强大到他他到哪儿都要寻找自希望和自由。所以说这个事情啊这个剧当中的激励激励啊。
确实不那么明显。
有同学说，re的需求是假设。
故事炫算B故事吗？red连主角都不算，他凭什么有B故事啊？re连主角都不算，他确实有成长，有转变，但你不要理解为B故事，没有这个必要啊。这个故事A和B就是外在的自由和内在的自由。因为安y。
安迪，我们说安迪作为绝对的主角，他追求了两个自由，一个是他内心的自由，一个是他肉体的自由。他开始对肉体自由放弃的时候，他追求的是。
内心的自由。但是后来呢他又追求了肉体的自由，而且后来也揭秘了，他妈从一开始就筹划肉体自由了。
他只是没有实施而已，明白吗？所以我还讲过，这个是先追求精神，再追求肉体，这个故事很高级，对吧？很高级，这才是AB故事啊。有同学说设计关键套关键道具有没有思路，关键道具其实还是位置的问题呀？
关键道具其实还是位置的问题啊，就是你如果上来就就给关键道具，那这个关键道具在关键时刻它不一定能用上。你如果前面藏的好，对吧？没有点透，那你关键时刻可以用它。但关键道具我觉得设计起来并没有什么难。
有同学说安迪是不是基利型的主角，当然是呀，因为安迪从头到尾其实还是蛮坚定的啊，所以你把它理解为成激利型主角，其实没有关系呃，其实是ok的对，确实他的人物弧线啊没有那么明显啊，像这种非常正的这种剧啊，人物弧线确实没有什么获得奥斯卡奖的阿根正传。
是催化剂主角的更典型代表阿甘不可能有成长的，他是个傻子，对吧？我们说阿甘正传这个电影更是催化剂主。
肖申克的救赎跟他同年角逐奥斯卡的，但失败了啊失败。
确实比较催化剂主角啊。
有个同学说，非人形的反派怎么写才好写哦，比如疾病这种，那你必须也把疾病外化成这个这个钱。
这个这个医生对吧？阻这些阻碍呀。
把它外化出来呀，对吧？
还是要外化出来才能写对抗呀。单单是疾病，天天在那疼这个这个东西这个对抗也不明显呀，写这种疾病这种类型的对抗还也必须把它外化出来。
有个同学说，如果这部片子安迪没有越狱这个动作，而是自己完成救赎，还翻案成功。
还能算作神作吧，那就肯定不能了呀。同学们，我们我们可以再次领悟一下啊，就是这部电影为什么在后来成为了一个神作啊？就是因为我们要对抗。
这个制度就这个制度是恶的。你现在说利用这个制度方案了，那你是承认这个制度是好的呀，那就他就不成为被制度化了呀。因为一个邪恶的制度是这个。
安迪对抗的是一个邪恶的制度，他要么被制度腐蚀，要么打破这个制度，他不可能说最后又利用这个制度又翻身了。那那这个制度就不邪恶了呀，懂吗？
他就那这个电影就不成立了。就如果他最后说哎找到证据又翻案了。典狱长哎呀。
嗯，原来你是无罪的，我送你出去吧啊，再见，大家一团和气。那这个制度它就不是就不是邪恶制度了呀，那就成好制度了呀。那还有什么被制度化呢？那整个电影就不存在了嘛？下次写这种类型的片子的时候，写好，吓死他们好吧，就这样吧，拜拜。
。